from inside Walter Reed hospital a
message from the president I came here
wasn't feeling so well I feel much
better now we're working hard to get me
all the way back I have to be back
because we still have to make America
great again we've done an awfully good
job of that and no regrets from Donald
Trump who was rushed to hospital late on
Friday I just didn't want to stay in the
white house I was given that alternative
stay in the white house lock yourself in
don't ever leave don't even go to the
Oval Office just stay upstairs and enjoy
it don't see people don't talk to people
and just be done with it and I can't do
that I had to be out front and this is
America this is the United
States but the White House message on
the president's illness has been
confused and incomplete on Saturday
morning the doctors gave a briefing but
that raised questions of when the
president was actually diagnosed the
president tweeted out the news early on
Friday morning just 72 hours into the
diagnosis now the first week of coid and
in particular Days 7 to 10 are the most
critical in determining the likely
course of this
illness at this time the team and I are
extremely happy with the progress the
president has made another of the
Consulting Physicians said the
experimental antibody cocktail
regenerant was administered 48 hours ago
and we're working very closely with the
company to monitor him but that would
mean the president was diagnosed on
Wednesday before two big campaign
rallies and a fundraiser and would
suggest regeneran was given 24 hours
earlier than the White House says it was
the first rule of Crisis Communications
one story one voice the White House has
failed to follow that and it has caused
confusion and medical experts say it
doesn't help that the briefing left a
number of questions unanswer for example
we were not told what type of fever the
president had how high did it go we were
not told with any Clarity whether or not
he in fact was or was not the recipient
of supplemental oxygenation
then adding to the confusion the
President's Chief of Staff Mark Meadows
who told reporters Trump's vital signs
in the past 24 hours have been
disturbing and the next 48 hours of
treatment are
critical all that has meant little to
the hundreds of supporters who've
gathered outside the hospital to sound
their support for the president but the
crucial period is still to come for Co
patients 5 to 10 days in is critical for
now the president is in the best place
for treatment even if he insists he's
ready to head back to the White House
Alan fiser Al jazer at the Walter Reed
Hospital Bethesda
Maryland PJ Crowley is a former White
House Deputy press secretary he says
this crisis will only add to an already
strained White House team and a
re-election
campaign this white house has a
tremendous you know credibility problem
um and and not only on this issue but on
a wide range of issues uh look the the
timing of this uh is very inopportune
for the White House 30 days before the
election everyone's sensitive about what
they say um but I I think you have a
white house that has relied too heavily
on the president's tweets and the
president's rallies um you don't have a
season team behind the president here we
are in year four by this stage in almost
any Administration it'll be it'll be
moving forward in all cylinders but
you're on your fourth Chief of Staff
your fourth press secretary you know
this is a a um a White House staff that
the president does not trust
significantly all of these things are
compounding a very very difficult
situation I think that was a very useful
video by the president I think he's
beginning the process of trying to get
on top of of the crisis the Corona virus
was going to be the
dominating uh issue for the campaign
anyway um and and as long as the
president is on the on the shelf and on
the men a matter of days uh you know
this actually inhibits them from talking
about almost anything else